il 30 novembre del 2014 sono tornata a
casa molto stanca dopo
un weekend molto impegnativo
pescara era una donna
stasera arrivo verso le 11 e mezza e non
potevo andare subito a dormire dovevo
spiaggiarsi un pochino sul divano quindi
mi metto lì ben piazzata con la
copertina di file in quel momento
suona il telefono sono il telefono ed et
essi la mia cara amica tessi paola sono
iniziate le doglie
la scadenza era il 15 dicembre
ovviamente mi alzo risveglio una delle
mie sorelle
prendiamo andiamo là perché nel
frattempo c'è il piccolo favor che ha
sette anni e non lo possiamo lasciarli
da solo il compagno di testa in quel
momento è a ragusa dove sta lavorando si
è già preso le ferie ma se le prese
contando sulla scadenza della nascita e
così vado vado in ospedale arriviamo
verso le dodici e mezza una notte
meravigliosa
veramente stupenda e verso verso le 5
del mattino arriva viene alla luce
letteralmente la piccola vittoria
una meraviglia se si ha un posto
speciale nel mio cuore
nella mia vita direi anche nella nella
vita di tante persone ha un posto
speciale non solo perché ha condiviso
nella casa in cui abito con le mie
sorelle un pezzo della sua vita un paio
d'anni quando favore nato non solo
perché ho avuto il meraviglioso regalo
di assistere alla nascita di due dei
suoi tre figli
non solo perché oggi vive a ragusa e
questi 1500 chilometri si spezzano un po
il cuore non solo per questo ma perché
credo che contessi ho imparato
ho sperimentato effettivamente che le
esperienze di vita per quanto distanti
per quanto lontane possano davvero in
qualche maniera a toccarsi posso so che
contessi il dolore che lei ha provato
per dell'esperienza è davvero così
diverse dalle mie
quello stesso dolore io lo posso
comprendere
io lo posso toccare lo posso guardare
perché ci si ritrova ad avere davvero un
linguaggio comune al di là di quello che
abbiamo vissuto
gli psicologi la chiamano empatia questa
cosa questo sguardo questo questo
sentimento che si tocca
e questa empatia sicuramente mi aiuta mi
mi sprona nel mio lavoro in tutte le
donne che in questi anni ho avuto la
fortuna di incontrare a trovare appunto
quello sguardo comune quel linguaggio
comune perché il dolore la gioia l'amore
la passione
sono comuni a tutti non sono solo di
qualcuno si guardano sempre sono sono
letteralmente appunto comuni
l'empatia forse corre un rischio che è
quello che si possa arrivare a
categorizzare quello che si vive che
quindi ogni gioia la riporta alla gioia
che io vivo ogni dolore lo riporto al
dolore che io ho vissuto ogni passione
ogni amore ecco forse il rischio è un
pochino quello di far rientrare tutto
nelle mie categorie
e allora quello che mi aiuta è quello di
provare a guardare ea toccare la vita
delle persone che incontro delle donne
che incontro non solo con l'empatia ma
anche con chiamiamola con simpatia cioè
con quella modalità che dice che
riconosce che quello che stai vivendo è
diverso da quello che ho vissuto io e da
quello che sto vivendo io
eppure io lo posso guardare con simpatia
la simpatia al talvolta la consideriamo
con superficialità e invece è proprio in
questo turbinio 3 empatia e simpatia che
io posso da un lato toccare dall'altro
guardare guardare con una certa distanza
e lasciarmi abitare poi da questa
simpatia è così che ho provato alcune
esperienze meravigliose che è quello per
esempio di mangiare il pride rais che
probabilmente non avrei mai provato se
non conoscendo qualcuno che me lo faceva
provare le planta inflitte riesco a
guardare
persino con simpatia quei riti così
distanti così diversi con questo modo
così diverso dal mio
eppure lo posso guardare con simpatia
con rispetto
questo non è solo una categoria
professionale non so come dirvi questo
non è una cosa che io strutturato nel
mio lavoro e che rimane quello che io
faccio per rapportarmi con le donne che
hanno vissuto delle esperienze negative
riguarda tutti riguarda ogni incontro
che mi può capitare e questo mi permette
di guardare alla bellezza alla bellezza
davvero che abita che abita ogni donna
ogni ogni vita simpatia empatia insieme
mescolate in questa specie di danza mi
permettono di vedere e soprattutto di
scoprire in me quando mi vengono donate
empatia simpatia insieme mi vengono
donate riesco a guardare quella devo
rubare la frase a una mia cara amica
alla mia amica eliah riesco a vedere la
bellezza delle donne forti la bellezza
delle donne forti e è quella bellezza di
quei volti segnati dalle rughe non tanto
del tempo ma della vita la bellezza di
chi riesce a camminare ancora con fatica
ma con desiderio la bellezza delle donne
forti e di chi ha saputo rialzare la
testa dalle fatiche che ha vissuto la
bellezza delle donne forti e quella
bellezza di chi vuole alzare lo sguardo
per guardarti negli occhi perché non gli
basta uno sguardo sfuggente ma vuole
guardarti negli occhi la bellezza delle
donne forti e quella di chi sa ridere di
se stessa di chi ha desiderio di
mostrare le proprie fragilità non ha
paura di essere fragile di chi sa
prendersi cura
di chi non ha paura di essere guarita
questo è il dono che mi è stato fatto in
questa danza
non so come altro dirlo tra empatia e
simpatia
questo è quello che mi ha cambiato la
vita nel relazionarmi con tante donne e
nel sentirmi relazionata in questa
maniera da tante donne perché mi ha
fatto venire fuori la mia bellezza e non
mi sarà tolta in nessuna maniera
questo voglio donare a voi ecco questo è
un po se è possibile bilancio un po la
palla per per dire che questa è una
responsabilità che ci tocca tutti
empatia simpatia in un balletto in una
danza comune per davvero provare a
guardare questa meravigliosa bellezza
grazie
[Applauso]